Wow if anyone was to contact me during
the next two weeks I'll be in the Oregon
State home for the pooped
they asked me to say it I don't know I
had to say it
to present the next Oscar here's a
gentleman who is 1/3 himself the lovable
Walter Brennan
tell me Waldo how'd you get in or should
we left the gate open nominees for the
best performance by an actress and
supporting ruler Grace Kelly and
Mogambo Metro golden man Geraldine page
and Hondo a Wayne fellows production
Warner Brothers Margery Rambo in torch
song metro-goldwyn-mayer Donna Reed and
from here to eternity Columbia Thelma
Ritter and pick up on South Street
20th Century Fox to win it please thank
you the winner is Donna Reed
thank you thought it was a long walk I
didn't think I was going to make it well
I'm very proud and I'm very grateful
especially to Columbia Pictures it was a
wonderful wonderful experience from here
to eternity but I think even more
wonderful is from eternity to here thank
or she's so excited back there you see
what I can see